[Musique]
comme tous les week-ends du sport au
programme aussi dans les yvelines on va
voir l'essentiel un des résultats
sportifs avec mitel et demi d'euros
bonsoir dans sa galerie de la rédaction
de tv 60,18 le journaliste sport de
cette rédaction on commence par du rugby
mitchell la fédérale 2 on n'était pas
loin de la victoire pour plaisir
pourtant plaisir avait mis tous les
ingrédients pour réussir à emporter à la
victoire mais une deuxième mi temps de
folie n'a pas suffi lors de la 9e
journée de fédérale 2 après un premier
acte dominé par chartres 17 à 10 des
rugbymans plaisir oies se sont ressaisis
en deuxième période devant leur public
qu'ils arrivent à inscrire deux essais
dont un à deux minutes de la fin du
match pour passer devant 24 à 17
mais en quelques minutes leurs espoirs
de victoire s'effondre chartres marque
un essai de pénalité puis arrive à
inscrire une pénalité quelques secondes
plus tard ce qu'en finale le 27 à 24
pour les visiteurs des faits de jeu
effectivement des des coups de pieds
qu'on envoie directement en touche des
choses non maîtrisée des quelques
touches aussi con conquête qu'on n'a pas
de trois ballons qui nous manque
énormément forcément à 24 partout au
look de pénalité pour gagner
effectivement bombe a eu de la m ouais
ça s'est joué à deux trois faits de jeu
sur la fin
et malheureusement ça tourne ça tourne
contre nous encore nous avons fait
plaisir se retrouve désormais à la 10e
place du classement de fédérale 2 avec
seulement deux victoires au compteur
l'équipe se retrouve en danger pour la
suite de la saison
forcément on va on va on va pas mettre
la charrue avant les boeufs et voilà on
va être humble encore une fois on a
travaillé avec humilité mais voilà on va
tout faire pour se maintenir encore une
fois cette année pour se ressaisir et
continuer à croire au maintien les
plaisirs aux âges auront sur le terrain
d'orléans le 8 décembre prochain les
derniers à du championnat grégory du
handball pour poursuivre michael le
championnat de nationale 2 féminine
après une mauvaise série de deux
défaites consécutives montigny le
bretonneux se reprend les i monteyne se
sont imposés sur le terrain de patronage
laïque et granville sur le score de 23 à
la meilleure buteuse côté montigny le
bretonneux se prénomme delgado des
gracques a avec 7 buts entrer ce tir
avec cette victoire la smb emballe
pointe à la 5e place à deux petits
points de la première place détenue par
tall carantec
on termine par
du football ce n'est pas un résultat
mais un match important à venir un
agenda
le tirage au sort du 8e tour de la coupe
de france de football a eu lieu la
semaine dernière et versailles qualifié
après sa victoire 3 à 2 face à sainte
marie à la réunion a été épargné dernier
représentant évinois se déplacera chez
un club de nationale 3 vire ce tour est
le dernier avant l'entrée en lice des
clubs de ligue 1 en 32e de finale
l'année dernière versailles s'est arrêté
à ce huitième tour de la compétition
contre lens on va croiser les doigts
pourquoi pas pour une belle affiche
contre un club de ligue 1 avec nos amis
de versailles merci michael pour ce tour
d'horizon bien plus de résultats des
reportages et des annonces aussi
d'événements sportifs
à suivre dans votre émission sept huit
sports le 7-8 sport c'est dans quelques
minutes sur tv 78